if we look at forrest gump
does he have defining moments
wow that's a really interesting question
um
so forrest
yeah he experiences a moment
that
doesn't transform his inner nature his
inner nature is
is constant he is
he's an innocent
that's his genius
but when the movie opens he's an
innocent alone
and
the moment that he climbs onto the
school bus and meets jenny
defines his life
his life will never be the same after
that moment that he climbs onto the
school bus and in fact there's dialogue
in the film
where he says you know it's
i can't quote it but it's you know it's
funny what a a person remembers i don't
remember my first pair of shoes etc he
says but i do remember
the first time i heard the sweetest
voice in the whole wide world
and he meets jenny on the bus she
invites him to sit beside her
and he says in very defining moment
language from that moment on
we was like peas and carrots
so
he experiences
a moment that defines him even though it
doesn't redefine his inner nature it
defines his experience of life
i think that
when forrest
finds out he's got a son
that is a transforming moment
it redirects the course of his life his
life will now be about
caring for a
little forest
and i think that jenny's death
it is also probably a defining moment
for him because
um
his life at least as told in the movie
is bookended by meeting jenny
and then
losing jenny
but receiving from her the gift
of his son
and that then
will define
the rest of forrest's life
so
defining moments don't always transform
say the nature of a person
but they can still change the course of
of their lives i think we see that with
jack in titanic
jack is not a character who really has a
big need to grow and change
rose definitely needs to be transformed
when we meet rose she's ready to leap
off
the back of the ship to her death
by the time the movie's done
rose is all about surviving
so she has been transformed jack is
still kind of the same guy
but i think we could say that
meeting rose
is a defining moment for jack
and uh
if he had not met her
his
certainly those whatever three or four
days of the voyage would have been
different and while that sounds like a
short period of time that was
that was his whole life
that was all the life he had left
he might also say winning that card game
that got him the ticket on titanic would
also be a defining event in his
life
yeah so with forrest gump it seems as if
there were maybe stronger in some sense
turning point like in terms of the
defining moments that changed a lot of
the people because if you look at
lieutenant dan
he was so angry he was so competitive he
had so much vengeance and then toward
the end when you see him at the wedding
he's he's a different person he's
transformed yes so for lieutenant dan
uh his life
was on a clear course
toward what he thought was his destiny
which was to die heroically in battle
which that was what his
family did
and
forrest intervened and
pulled him out of danger and
disrupted
the course that lieutenant dan thought
his life was supposed to be on so that
was a moment that redefined lieutenant
dan's life in a way lieutenant dan
despised
and
then lieutenant dan was on that course
of being completely unhappy with a life
that he saw as uh he's been cheated
so all he's got now is just
emptiness uh until
he is on
uh the shrimping boat in the middle of
the hurricane with forest
and he climbs up the mast in the middle
of that hurricane and has a screaming
match with god
over his destiny and forrest tells us
that
in that moment
he believes that
god and lieutenant dan somehow
came to peace with each other
and lieutenant dan is a different person
after that which makes possible
lieutenant dan showing up at the wedding
now he's got new legs he has a wife and
he's no longer
the bitter person
he's been made whole
and we within the movie we have the two
pivot points uh the
rescue which denied him his destiny
and then
the
confrontation
between lieutenant dan and god in the
midst of a hurricane which then makes
his growth possible so we can only
understand lieutenant dan's character
arc
through those two pivot points
and then with jenny
here she recommends for forrest you know
to run
to run from the bullies but really
that's a metaphor for what she'd been
doing all her life
and so we don't see her
toward the end until you know
she comes back and she's changed but we
just know that she was a runner
herself and then she's she's much
different
yes and
in many ways
the moment that made it possible for her
to
come home
happened off screen
we we understand
well
we see her hit bottom when she when she
climbs up on that railing of a balcony
at a new year's eve party i think
and so we understand
that
uh either we've seen a defining moment
or that she is in the zone where those
things kind of happen
her return to forest is evidence
that she has
had this transformative kind of
experience
but i think it shows us that defining
moments can be
kind of if we're talking about playing
cards they can be played in different
ways they can be played on screen off
screen
through
just a character recounting something
that happened
or
we we end up with more defining moments
than we can actually use it's one of my
frustrations i was working today on my
next feature screenplay and the last two
pages after fade out are a nice little
dialogue scene that tells the story of
my main character's defining moment and
i know that that's going to fall out of
the script
because it just
it doesn't need to be in there
but i needed to know what that moment
was
so that i could write the rest of what
that character says and does
so even when these defining moments
don't end up on screen they still enrich
my understanding
this is also something that can be
really
valuable for actors
for them to understand not only
that
this is true of my character
but why this is true of my character
so i'll
tell a story
out of school
when i worked at warner brothers in the
script department
the movie twister started shooting
before the script was fully written
and
[Music]
producer ian bryce called me up and said
can you send a script typist to oklahoma
to work with the writer as he finishes
writing this movie while we shoot it
and i said that sounds like too much fun
i'll send myself
so i was on a plane the next day to
oklahoma city and i ended up out in the
middle of a farm field with
300 vehicles and
making this big tornado action movie
helen hunt plays
a meteorologist who's chasing tornadoes
obsessively
for reasons that
no one knew at the moment because that
scene hadn't been written yet
so
she's having to go out and
um
try she's trying to put this psyc um
scientific instrument place it in the
path of a tornado so it'll be sucked up
and they'll learn all kinds of things
about
tornadoes she's putting her life at risk
putting her relationships at risk
and
at some point they know will write the
scene for her backstory the defining
moment that made her a tornado hunter
but they didn't need to film that
for several weeks into the future
and they didn't seem to take into
account that helen hunt as an actor
would like to know
why she's doing all these things
eventually they came up with what we
would
describe as a defining moment a moment
from her childhood when she experienced
a killer tornado
and that
birthed in her the dream that she would
someday make the world safer by getting
people more advance warning of tornadoes
my argument is it would have
been a real service
to helen hunt as an actor
to know what that was
while she was
chasing those tornadoes
and that i i'll just use as a metaphor
for the way that an understanding of
defining moments can be of use and a
value to
actors certainly
directors
editors
cinematographers
everyone
you know i described
the way
michael corleone is in the bathroom
in that
pivotal defining moment for the
godfather
you can see evidence
that everyone on the team appreciated
what that moment meant
for that character and for the film
the production designer had to design
three sets of doors
for
the character to walk through the
cinematographer had to arrange the shot
that way the editor
the composer
had to all support that moment not cut
past it because oh my gosh how much time
are we spending in this bathroom
nothing's going on in here
but everybody recognized that yes this
is where
michael is
going through this metamorphosis and so
we have to support
and
dramatize
all of the interaction
that is happening
outside of our view somehow we have to
make that visible on the screen and the
entire team
understood intuitively or not
what a defining moment that was and
built an entire
film around that moment
we've talked a lot about
defining moments in
drama
but in comedy as well i mean we could
think of so many john hughes films that
had great defining moments
uh whether it was 16 candles or or
home alone or something i mean
there's just
is there a difference in the way that a
comedic defining moment is done
you know i think
i i am not a comedy writer uh i it just
gives me terrible anxiety to think about
exchanging money for laughs
and i i have friends who
specialize in comedy i think it's a gift
that i don't have
but to the extent that i understand
comedy
comedy works a lot like drama
except it's just
funny you know we laugh so
when a character is pursuing a goal
they pursue it to absurd lengths
in a way that you wouldn't do in a drama
but
the character arcs
still often have to do with character
transformation
i think that the deepest and and like
most satisfying
uh comedies really are dramas with
laughs and so
i i think that these
defining moments absolutely exist
um you might need a moment a defining
moment to help us understand
why a character would do the absurd
things that they do
but
so that you know they may be a of a
different quality when i brainstorm my
20 possibilities i'm going to pick a
different defining moment in a comedy
than i am in a
gritty drama
just for tone
but it's still performing
those functions of
either explaining why the hero wants
what they want
why they need to grow and change the way
they need to
or that's showing us the transformation
as it unfolds step by step